as a quick you know Pro tip for
everybody if you've got stuff that
people ask you to do for them because
you're good at it maybe you're good at
Tech it's like can you help me set up my
like Wi-Fi and stuff you know blah blah
blah it's like that means you're solving
problems you can chart like what people
ask you to do as a favor is an
indication of the things you can charge
for later right so
I had all these people who are asking me
uh not all these I mean a handful of
people who had asked me for programs and
stuff and so what I did was during my
last year of Consulting I started
something called the free training
project and so the free training project
was I would charge 500 to a thousand
dollars but I would I wouldn't charge it
they had to donate that to the charity
their choice in exchange to work with me
right and so that way I wanted people to
Value it but they weren't paying me
directly so they'd get a write-off they
felt good I had a ton of Goodwill also
in the marketplace too because I was
like I'm doing all this stuff for
charity I got I got all these people
reaching out to me like this is so cool
blah blah blah right
and so after a year of doing that I had
probably I don't know 12 really good
tests of like great before and after
pictures that I had collected from my
clients and I told them that was part of
the deal I was like I'll like you have
to donate it I would like to do this for
real later but
um you have to let me use your
testimonial they were like that's fine
so once I had that
um I had those first you know 10 12
customers who had who had great before
and after pictures
um I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm doing I'm going
to do this full-time now are you
comfortable paying the same amount
you're paying to charity except just
making a charity of Alex because Alex
can't eat either and so and that was
actually how I transitioned from
not-for-profit or donating everything
and I'd even set up the entity I just
told them to literally donate it and
send me the screenshot I didn't even do
anything like that
um and so I didn't have a website
all I had was an LLC and a PayPal
account so like for everybody's like I
don't know how to start a business I was
like you literally just need a bank
account and a way to process money that
is it like two things and you can Google
how to figure out if you can't figure it
out from Google entrepreneurship might
not be for you all right but you look
like think about there's 30 million
business in the United States 30 million
other people have figured this out
which means you can too so bank account
payment processing make the first 10
free or some sort of charitable thing so
that people like don't feel weird or you
don't feel weird about selling Etc after
you have it after providing this service
to people you can transition people from
free service to paid service and if they
don't want to start paying you then that
gives you insight as to either you suck
right or they suck which is also
possible too but either way
a certain percentage of those people
will continue to stay and pay and now
you have income now you can also ask
those people for referrals which is
exactly what I did so I think half that
business came in just for I got you know
the initial ones came in from friends
and family and me posting and so I was
I'll close the loop on what I said
earlier a year later after I had the
testimonials I made a public post being
like hey I've got this thing now I made
a website which is that was my big
announcement I made a website I still
have the post I found it it's 2013. uh I
was like I made it I made a website and
uh I I am now open for business and so
if you would like you know training
stuff let me know
um this is what I'm doing now you know I
had some testimonials and go check out
the site whatever and so from there I
was able to get I think about 20 guys uh
who were willing to let me do just like
almost bodybuilding type stuff because I
was kind of like what I was powerless
back then and so
um I think I want to say I got 20 guys
at 200 bucks a month and so I was making
four thousand dollars a month
uh from those people and it took me four
hours every Saturday to do the
Fulfillment what was the Fulfillment I
would just I would just update their
training programs and and send them
nutrition uh like update their macros
updated meal plans
um and then like you know new workouts
before the week Etc
um and then I and everyone had my cell
phone and I would just text them the new
stuff and if they had any questions they
could hit me up like it was a very
simple business
um and so that's what I did it was just
one-on-one online and it only took me
four hours on Saturday morning and to
show you what kind of person I am I
hated it uh even though I loved Fitness
I hated having to do something the same
thing every day
um like on the delivery side so I ended
up having the genius idea of saying oh I
need to own a gym because then I'll be a
business owner I'm really just
self-employed right now
um and so that's what got me to start my
gym rather than probably doing the wiser
decision and saying okay this cost you
four hours a week and you're making four
grand a month maybe you should do this
for 40 hours a week but doing more of it
to me felt like a horrible idea so I
didn't want to do anymore
um so how did you jump from that to
therefore I should probably own a gym oh
I don't think that's that's the
difference yeah it was not a good it was
not an intelligent one I always thought
I was going to own a gym that was I mean
that was the not always I had done a so
so these are the three things that I was
deciding between for my business I was
decided between a test prep company
because I was really good at
standardized testing
um and I had a process for how I how I
did it I had a yogurt business idea
because I was a big Froyo guy yeah I
know I was like I'm a Avid consumer of
this [__] yeah I feel like I know and I
and I hated there's so many things I
knew that I thought I could I actually
know a lot about the other business now
um and I was good at Fitness so those
are the three things that I felt like I
could do for anybody's listening like
those are the three that I was picking
between the yogurt business cost 250
Grand to start up I didn't have that
money so I couldn't do that one
um I had saved about 50 or 60 Grand I
can't remember 50 or 60 at the time
um I was 23. and then uh the test prep
business I actually did a ton of work on
um and I was going to partner with a
professor from my University to do it
with me and so I set up all the initial
materials
um and based on a miscommunication I'll
just put it that way
um he ended up either taking the
materials and not and using them without
me to start a business Consulting thing
either way it became clear that what I
thought was happening versus what he
thought was happening were not the same
thing
um and that left a very sour taste in my
mouth with test prep I do think it was a
smarter business I probably should have
done
um and so all that was left was Fitness
and so Fitness I was like I already know
that people already want me to help them
with it so I'll just start that and so
the gym was the the was the what uh what
I would have said is like the legit
business I didn't think that the online
thing was legitimous remember this is 10
years ago so like it wasn't what I don't
even thought it was that was a that was
a concept of legitimate business you
know what I mean so I was really early
days on it and so uh you know from there
I hit up 40 gym owners uh to see if uh I
could just basically Apprentice for them
and just work for free uh one guy hit me
back he had a mastermind uh I joined his
Mastermind for ten thousand dollars even
though I didn't have a gym and I said
are you sure that it makes sense for me
to join he's like oh yeah sure
um and it did actually make sense for me
because then I could learn from all the
mistakes everybody else was making
before I started so I was like okay this
works and so I learned all the stuff
that I could from that Mastermind and
from him
um he ended up signing me as an employee
yeah there's actually a couple questions
on that front yeah so um yeah the the
test prep thing is interesting I didn't
I didn't know that part of the story
except my first business that went well
was also a test prep business and I
still have the Evernote document from
2012 where I was like [__] I need to
make some money what am I good at uh and
what could I possibly do and it was like
test prep and web design I was like cool
let me make a test of course thing and
let me advertise it on a website because
back then it was hard to make a website
look pretty and that that's what ended
up ended up making the money initially
um on the on the gym front so
it it seems to me like there's two leaps
there
um leap number one is I want to do this
thing like I start a gym maybe
um and therefore I'm gonna work for free
I wanted to own a business yeah I want
to own a business therefore I'm going to
work for someone for free that that is
seems like a bit of a leap uh which
these days seems very unfashionable to
even say because everyone then goes down
your throat for being that's only
available for the privileged etc etc
that's a privilege working for food yeah
the working for free thing it's it's
quite unfashionable to suggest that
people work for free
so I made money from that now I offered
to work for free but I he quickly was
like I don't feel good about it I'll
just pay you and so he paid me he paid
me like minimum wage but I mean I think
I made like I don't know 2800 bucks a
month whatever it was I don't even
remember what it was because I made more
from the four hours a week on Saturday
than I did from that but I again but the
point wasn't to to to earn you know I
mean it was to learn and I had saved up
50 Grand so I knew I could live for you
know at least two years on that
um I tried to live when I was I was I
spent 400 bucks a month splitting a
bedroom
um and then I ate not you know I spent a
hundred dollars a week on food I was
eating you know I was spending nothing
to live and then the rest of my time was
at the gym trying to learn hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day